first up today in our news vogue's make  cover girl the stunning mom-to-be  rihanna that's right  when she got pregnant rihanna says that  she knew one thing  she'd never see a maternity aisle  because she loves to dress up she talks  about the father of the baby her partner  asap rocky and she says she doesn't want  guys out of the friend zone easy and  she's known him for a decade but  everything changed over the pandemic  when they took a road trip just the two  of them across the country in a tour bus  oh god she's not sure if she's having a  baby shower but if she does it'll be  co-ed with cocktails she says she wants  people to leave plastered and crawling  out yes god she is everything everything